la sieste un moment privilégié défendu
par quelques irréductibles depuis
plusieurs décès dans les années 70
l'homme de lettres yvan audouard se
qualifier même de propagandistes de la
sieste c'est un exercice qui devrait
être reconnu de salubrité publique
un avis partagé par d'autres cieux
hester professionnel en 1995
ces policiers du sud de la france terre
de sieste incontestable pesait de ce
moment une priorité moi j'avais sûrement
la recherche sur le divan j'arrête là je
m'endors et je me réveille quand je me
réveille tôt environ 16 heures dans la
nature dans les transports en commun ou
directement dans la rue la sieste se
pratique partout et pour certains
politiques les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale font aussi bien la faire grand
spécialiste du genre
l'ancien député raymond barre on se
moquait gentiment lionel juste en 1988
c'est vrai qu'on lui a vu faire à
l'assemblée des siestes glorieuse des
siestes béate des repos réparateur
après déjeuner superbe des siestes
d'accord mais pas trop longtemps
quinze minutes pas plus paroles des
scientifiques une consigne dont certains
secteurs n'ont que faire vous dormez
longtemps 2h 3h pour est bon 3 heures
c'est que c'est pas très bon pour la
santé dans l'air pour longtemps de plus
à ça près d'autres militants de la
sieste vont même jusqu'à l'imposer sur
leur lieu de travail en 2015 cette
salariée était à l'origine de cette
salle zen
lassé de devoir se cacher pour se
reposer j'ai carrément fait dacia
sûrement le travail dans mon véhicule
pendant plusieurs mois avant l'ouverture
de sa seule scène parce que j'étais
enceinte et ça ne m'était vraiment
nécessaire pour pouvoir perdurer dans le
temps pour revenir travailler en fait
qu'elle soit pratiquée au travail à
l'assemblée ou en pleine nature le plus
dur finalement avec la sienne
c'est le réveil
[Musique]